guten morgen und hallo es ist donnerstag
das heißt es ist militärisch fitness
steht so wie letzte woche hat es
körperliches intensives workout
aufgebaut so wie gewohnt erklärt und
dann gemeinsam trainiert wir das ist die
nici der herbert und ich später wir
leiten euch wieder durch das programm
und werden schauen dass wir auch heute
den ganzen körper mit euch richtig durch
trainieren sodass ihr in den tag hinein
starten können mit viel energie ok jetzt
bereit herbert nicke alles bereit alles
da wir starten mit einem lockeren
absteigern dass ich in der intensität
aber dann bis hin zum kompletten
programm wo es dann richtig intensiv für
das heißt wir beginnen mit stadtlauf
wieder ganz locker im stand laufen
kreislauf in schwung bringen und so wie
auch jeden tag auch heute donnerstag wir
sind getestet wir sind negativ alles gut
gestern haben wir noch ein korporal
wagen gehabt der uns entsprechend die
eine muss etwas näher gebracht hat das
heißt das kann man natürlich jederzeit
auf youtube nachschauen sollte man da
auch die motivation haben und
entsprechend das jetzt alles gemerkt
haben das video ist online
ihr findet es okay dann kurz ist
mobilisieren wir beginnen mit dem
sprunggelenk das heißt ein weinstand
rechtes bein hochheben und kreisen im
sprunggelenk richtung wechseln
wir bleiben auf der seite nur begreifen
und nicht des sprunggelenks und wir
greifen im kniegelenk das ist es wird
jetzt fürs gleichgewicht stört bislang
herausforderung die richtung wechseln
und die seite wechseln beginnen wieder
mit dem sprunggelenk gleichgewicht
finden dort zum anfassen wenn es einfach
ein punkt fixiert am boden vor euch und
konzentriert und auf den schutz und die
richtung wechseln
und wieder drehen im kniegelenk auch
hier die richtung wechseln
genau und wieder abstellen die beine
wir laufen wieder kurzem stand das kam
jetzt aber schluss und dynamischer
machen das heißt vom eingehen beginnen
sie haben jetzt einen lockeren trab lauf
der jetzt langsam aber sicher intensiver
wird mit knie heben mit anfassen
unterschiedlichste varianten ein paar
schritte laufen eine bewegung dazu ein
baum genau so werden wir danach munter
und wir sind beim training dann richtig
angekommen
kurz aus lockern nächste ist gelenk was
man mit mobilisieren versucht gesenkt da
man gestern vom christopher tolle übung
gesehen
im kreis stets am boden das heißt 12
positionen bei teilnehmen und diesen
nach innen und nach außen drehen
so haben wir tolle mobilisation ein
hüftgelenk mit drinnen genau nehmen
gleich unter reviers bereich der unteren
wirbelsäule mit der lendenwirbelsäule
das heißt die beine anwinkeln und die
kniegelenke links und rechts am boden
ablegen genau hin und her bewegen
es ist hilft natürlich mit dabei aber
der untere rücken auch schon mitbringen
und wir bleiben nur arme in der position
die beine schließen die knie zusammen
und beide hin und her bewegen
und jetzt wird man dann bereit sein das
alter bereich der lendenwirbelsäule mal
gewisse vor erwärmung hat okay bitte
wieder aufstehen wir gehen in eine neue
bewegung das haben wir bis jetzt gemacht
dass jetzt manchmal sehr viel am stand
bewegt jetzt nehmen wir mal zwei linien
oder ein abstand von zwei metern was hat
des wohnzimmers am platz hergibt und
laufen einmal hin und her so was wie
linien läuft könnte man es bezeichnen
gegeben dass ihnen im weg steht und geht
schon los das heißt hier bewegt sich von
einer ende vom raum zum anderen gibt's
am boden kurz ab und wir starten haben
wir in einer normalen intensität in
einer normalen geschwindigkeit sehr gut
macht das super okay wir mobilisieren
weiter wir kreisen wieder unsere arme
wird kreisen die arme vorwärts und
rückwärts
und wie man sich ein paar tage geübt
haben vielleicht gezeigt ein bisserl
besser eine vorwärts rückwärts und dass
keine steigerung koordinativ dazu gebe
jetzt dann nur die aufgabe die richtung
zu wechseln auf signal locker auf
kommando okay ist wechselt die richtung
und wechsel und wechsel muss man gut
aufpassen und denken in welche richtung
man weiter dreht wechsel gerne und
wieder auslaufen
sie ärgert dann vertreten hat den
oberkörper auf die linke seite und auf
die rechte seite
wir nehmen den kopf in der bewegung mit
wir nehmen auch die hüfte in der
bewegung mit das ist der erste teil
jetzt aufpassen ist fixiert die hüfte
der oberkörper dreht sich aber weiter
und der kopf dreht sich mit aber die
hüfte bleibt stabil
genau und jetzt machen wir nur den kopf
stabile dazu dass der blick ist gerade
aus der hüfte stabil und wir drehen nur
den körper hin und her genau perfekt
macht sie das okay und da lassen wir am
stand jetzt wieder mit signal start
stopp habe sie schneller werden und dann
wieder normal weiterlaufen statt
stop & start stop & start stopp und
wieder aus locker nächste übung ihr
macht es wieder einen crash schritt und
wir geht es den rumpf in die vorbeuge
und rumpf kreisen bzw rumpf drehen in
der vorbeuge die übung kämmer schule
haben wir fast täglich gemacht gute
variante zum aufwärmen und atmen nicht
vergessen seit der art mit jede bewegung
der körper braucht den sauerstoff ok
dann wechsele man auch mit dem pendel
auf ich gehe wieder ein schritt zurück
dass in einem weg stellen jetzt schloss
jetzt macht man so dass wir drei vier
längen langsam macht und eine schnell
okay ich gehe es von mir das signal
eines und wieder langsam weiter und habe
eine schnell und wird weiter gehen und
aus lockern
wir schließen die hände kreisen im
handgelenk das wird ab belastet bei den
übungen die dann kommen
genau da kann man alles tempo variieren
langsam beginnen schneller wieder in
richtung wechseln kam auf und zuklappen
das heißt in einer ebene hin und her
genau dann gehen wir gleich eine
seitlich hoch und kreisen im
ellbogengelenk das motorrad ist eine
gelenkschmiere herstellen richtung
wechseln
und ausloggen wieder okay heiße duelle
wir beginnen ja nein wir fangen mal mit
jan wechseln gleich in die laienbewegung
das heißt blick wendung links rechts
ja nein vielleicht kopfnicken seitlich
und dann machen wir unsere halbkreise
bedienen auf der linken seite über die
brust abrollen auf die rechte seite
räumen hin und her rollen
weigert mobilisieren haben wir mal das
letzte mal beim militär fitness workout
ich hoffe ihr kennzeichen erinnern
letzten donnerstag an
47 denn sie erinnern was das war ja das
heißt liegestütz hammer kommt eine übung
sieht ups kniebeugen rücken jeweils
sieben wiederholungen commander ladet
viermal so beginnen wie gesagt mit sie
im liegestütz in den unterschiedlichsten
varianten das klassisch machen
ihr könnt das auch entsprechend etwas
erleichtert machen optionen gibt es
viele
dann gleiten wechsel in die sit ups da
auch wieder darauf achten die
schwierigkeit bestimmt die position der
arme arme in vorhalt dem auch das ganze
etwas leichter arme vor der brust wird
schon schwieriger und die arme bei der
schläfe ist dann noch ein bisschen
schwieriger dann gehen wir in die
kniebeuge beinachse achten hüftgelenk
kniegelenk sprunggelenk sollte in einer
ebene bleiben positiv runterdrücken
stabilisiert wirbelsäule in ihrem
natürlichen schwung muskulär gesichert
die punkte kennt sie alle
ich wiederhole nur dass man das nicht in
vergessenheit gerät für die übung rücken
übung bau klage oberkörper aufrichten
ohne schwung ohne reißen mit der
muskelkraft des rücken streckers
ok und dann bringt man eine bewegungs
variante mit dem spiel den linien love
mit boxen
das heißt box vorstellung ein geöffneter
position der beine hände bei der deckung
oben und ihr bewegt sich wieder links
und rechts hin und her und streckt dabei
die arme dazu beitragen dass technisch
nicht perfekt ist ja kein problem die
bewegung ist es was wichtig ist und die
bewegung ist die gezählt weil spätestens
wenn wir das tempo jetzt steigert dann
wird sie koordiniert deswegen lassen wir
jetzt mal aus anstatt okay jetzt kann es
mit 1000 bewegungen kann im jahr
aufwärmen das ist auch eine variante die
als zubringer für die selbstverteidigung
für militärische boxen gute variante ist
das heißt bau hat es immer wieder mit
ein allgemeines aufwärmen haben wir so
gut wie abgeschlossen jetzt gehen wir in
den spezifischen teil hinein
das heißt wir werden jetzt schauen dass
man aber bislang dynamisch reinkriegen
dass man ein bisschen das herz kreislauf
system wirklich vorbereiten auf das was
da an belastung kommt und da bietet sich
eine übung für mich ganz besonders an
jetzt das ist der mountain klein war
das haben die letzten tage immer
mitgemacht das heißt in die liegestütz
ausgangsstellung einmal jetzt das von
der seite einmal von vorn und geht's los
knie zur brust dynamische bewegung
kreislauf kommt in schwung muskuläre
arbeit im bereich der rumpfmuskulatur
zum stabilisieren
alles mit dabei starb wieder gerne
auslagern ausschütteln anschluss trinken
wir geben die übungen es nur gemeinsam
durch mit 30 sekunden belasten 30
sekunden börse zum sehen was kommt dann
auf euch zu und dann legen wir los
okay sagen wir die erste übung vor nicki
dem liegestütz in der variante heute
variante etwas erhöht mit bewegender
arme das heißt ich verlasse meine
position gehe auf der stiege hinauf
verstopft war charmant auf die couch was
findet das kleine erhöhung geht es
hinauf macht obenan liegestütz und
woanders wieder runter eine variante
variante nummer zwei hier wandert auf
die anhöhe hinauf mit den händen
einen liegestütz er wandert weiter nach
hinten zurück
unten einen wege steht ok und wieder
hinaus einige gestützt und hinunter
einen liegestützen und das ganze machen
wir jetzt 30 sekunden das heißt bei
durch die kraft ein
das wieder anstrengen 30 sekunden geht's
los und da bricht die gewisses die
körperspannung bleibt in jeder position
auch wenn ich mit den händen bewege und
die position verlassen sollte das becken
in einer gerade bleiben das heißt
kontrolliert dass sie wirklich einen
stabilen rumpfes wenn ihr auf und ab
marschiert ist jetzt dass bei der ig
perfekt dort bleibt das becken genau in
der position wie es ist noch zehn
sekunden dann hat es die ersten 30
sekunden erledigt 51 lockern aufstehen
hände ausschied und armee ausschied um
deutsche große belastung dar auf die
zweite übung der machen sind die stars
stern sprünge wie funktioniert das ja
ein vorbild denn genau das heißt wie
eine eine schnelle kniebeuge nach unten
mit geschlossenen beinen handy berühren
den boden und danach geht es in die
flugphase das heißt nach oben springen
arme und beine weg strecken so dass man
einen stern machen und dann passt ist
gut wo wir jetzt das ausschaut das
nichts im weg steht dass ich ein haus
und ich glaub ich meist bereit 30
sekunden gehts los
wie gesagt da noch eine andere variante
wo man die beinmuskulatur belasten für
die die das springen nicht ganz so gut
funktioniert das heißt breite kniebeugen
sogenannte super sports beinachse achten
ungefähr halb zaubershow und tief
hinunter gehen zusatzgewicht verwenden
[Applaus]
genau fünf sie konnten nur mit guter
dynamik drinnen und zeit aus 30 sekunden
belastet
wie gesagt einmal mit den kniebeugen
ohne sprung star james mit sprung ist
schon ganz schön anstrengend da kommt
herz kreislauf system schon in schwung
genau da kommt die der vater schon zum
schnaufen an
okay dann haben wir übung für die
bauchmuskulatur candlesticks oder auch
kerzen das ist vielleicht der begriff
die in dem einen oder anderen noch
bekannt ist nicht gut auf die bitten
zumal ford eine variante
genau hier liegt so einmal den
oberkörper am boden ab den kopf kennst
ganz entspannt auf die matte legen und
er streckt die beine nach oben und dann
aber wieder nach vorn zu probieren als
variante zusätzlich die beine ganz
ausstrecken wenn die lendenwirbelsäule
auf der matte haft und des gut
stabilisieren kennst dann können sie das
auch so machen danke
er hat eine variante mit zusatzgewicht
kette per flasche oder es ist möglich
etwas in die hand rollt zurück streckt
die beine zu kerze nach oben und dann
kommt mit schwung wieder vor und dann
versucht das ganze auszugleichen dass
die beinen am boden kommen sondern dass
sie das entsprechend stabilisieren
müssen bastian dankeschön
kurz nur durchschlafen in zehn sekunden
legen wir wieder los mit 30 sekunden
belastung 531 und los geht's
wie gesagt wichtig ist die spannung aus
der rumpfmuskulatur ist in jedem bereich
der bewegung gegeben da los sie nie
locker wurscht ob das die übung mit
zusatzgewicht in der dynamik drinnen ist
oder ob das die bewegung ohne
zusatzgewicht ist da bauch darum drücken
das ist stabil das ist meine gesundheit
und fdp muss sie achten so gut aus zehn
sekunden noch 21 30 sekunden wieder
pause okay aber aufstehen aus locker
nein der pause an schluck trinken wir
zeigen mit der nicht gleich in der
zwischenzeit dann eine variante in costa
ricanischen trinken ja ich sage euch die
variante die man jetzt nur als letzte
als vierte übung haben nicht gesagt
einmal deine eine option sei eine
variante
genau wir haben den streik sprung mit
einem mir gestürzt dabei die eine übungs
ausführung wer den liegestützen immer
kann weil die ersten 30 sekunden er
schon richtig sagt waren dann lasst den
weg ja okay ich habe deine variante auch
liegestütz sprung hoch das heißt bis mit
liegestützen eine variante ich kann es
mir auch frauen machen oder auch mit
liegestützen durch schütteln oder die
gelenke 20 sekunden und dann legen wir
los 30 sekunden bird ist mit liegestütz
streck sprung mit liegestützen zehn
sekunden
breit machen und los geht's wichtig ist
wenn ich mit den beinen zurückspringt
dass sie wirklich in einer schönen
körperspannung drinnen seit der politur
hängt oder zum himmel hinauf zeigt
sondern dass sie wirklich in einer
schönen position seit ihr habt es noch
quasi kunden hoffen derzeit 3 21 und
salat ausschlafen durchschnaufen wir
bereiten uns jetzt vor auf die wirkliche
intensive belastung ist als 20 sekunden
volle power zehn sekunden pause
die vier übungen zweimal durch dann auch
noch meine satzpause und nach der
satzpause machen wir das ganze normen
und dann ist das training schon wieder
erledigt ok als erinnerung noch wenn wir
diesen beitrag teilt und auch
kommentiert nehmen sie an der verlosung
unsere wasserflaschen teil das heißt
drei stück pro tag mit drinnen und das
ist ganz nette erinnerung das heißt
nutzt die chance und sichert euch
entsprechend so eine wasserflasche ihr
sexappeal antike und der herbert die
zahl rechte das ist diese wasserflasche
das ist ein nettes erinnerungsgeschenk
wie gesagt teilen und kommentieren
mit dabei
die luft holen einatmen ausatmen im kopf
vorbereiten dass sie jetzt wirklich
intensive belastung kommt mich als
ausbilder herbert göcke aufwärmen war
intensiv aber intensiv genug der körper
verletzt sich der körper trittin adware
und vor allem auf wir haben muss immer
den körper sorgen was kommt im hauptteil
was ist die belastung und die musik auch
schirme spüren und dann wirklich
leistungsfähig zu sein
okay mir gefehlt das sah ich sehe der
schweiß rinnt ja aber das ist ja nichts
schlechtes sein das ist in ordnung das
heißt gamers an 20 sekunden belasten und
zehn sekunden pause erst die übung war
der liegestütz hamann am stockerl auf
der couch zehn sekunden dann statt mehr
los position einnehmen 21 zeit läuft 20
sekunden und das tempo gestaltet die
natürlich selber wenn ihr richtig
richtig hohes tempo vor sie ist es
natürlich viel viel viel mehr noch für
sie als kreislaufsystem belastend und
wenn ihr das tempo langsam aber wenn es
ist mehr eine kraft gelassen und
kraftausdauer belastung halbzeitshow 15
sekunden vorbei ein fehler zehn sekunden
zeit aus 20 sekunden belastungen waren
auch im 30 sekunden rhythmus drinnen
bereitet sich auf die zweite übung vor
21 uhr geht's los star james
beziehungsweise kniebeugen breiter griff
breiter stand 10 sekunden sind vorbei
das heisst noch zehn sekunden 30 kunden
21 10 sekunden pause station wechseln
bauch übung das heißt einmal auf die
matte einmal noch kurz durchschnaufen in
drei sekunden 21 und es geht schon
wieder los
voller spannung forum spannung genau
halbzeit ist schon wieder recht 10
sekunden sind schon wieder vorbei
durchbeißen ja zusatzgewicht ist richtig
richtig anstrengen dynamische kerze ist
für bauch wie feuer und aus zehn
sekunden station wechseln macht sich
gleich wieder bereit für hobbys oder
strick sprung mit liegestütze und los
geht's und wie gesagt war es der
liegestützen immer ganz geht dann bleibt
einfach in der variante ohne liegestütz
weil wie gesagt das ist schon richtig
richtig fordert für den ganzen
organismus nach drei sekunden 21
rohstoff wir beginnen wieder mit übung
12 sekunden eine sekunde position
einnehmen und los gehts 20 sekunden wir
waren dann im liegestütz dass der kopf
in verlängerung der wirbelsäule bleibt
aber wenn ihr schon richtig angestrengt
sei es nicht leicht nach vorn blicken
bitte bei den liegestützen dann haben
wir richtig schöne position fünf
sekunden durch und das ist zehn sekunden
pause
es gibt schon richtig gar selber ja
schaut richtig anstrengend aus beneide
ich fast ein bisserl weiter gern
mitmachen
zwei sekunden eine und los gehts nächste
übung starts beziehungsweise wiederum
die kniebeugen mit dem breiten stand in
der dynamik runtergehen genau achten auf
die beinachse wichtig noch sieben
sekunden 321 10 sekunden station
wechseln bauch übung die nickel stellte
gewichte hinterher wird nimmt wie ein
fliegender wechsel 21 los geht's
selbert macht sie das zu hause mit
weißem durchbeißen halbzeit noch drei
sekunden 21 aus zehn sekunden station
wechseln curtis und strickt sprung mit
liegestützen oder auch ohne wir haben es
wieder zurück sagt einmal bitte
vorbereiten und los geht's genauer
kontrolliert seine kräfte jetzt letzte
übung erster durchgang zehn sekunden
da kann man auch mal das tempo erhöhen
21 und pause aus lockern ausgehen
trinken schatz dass der kreislauf sich
in den zwei minuten erholen kann die
muskulatur sich erholen kann
mobilisieren zwischen drinnen können
sehr gerne machen das ist eine gute
variante nummer zwischendrin den körper
bis runter zu fahren also diese
möglichkeiten haben sie jetzt muss wie
gesagt die zwei minuten länger bisschen
raus entspannt und spart die energie
damals der energie für den zweiten
durchgang noch einmal acht übungen mit
20 sekunden belasten und zehn sekunden
pause wie gesagt auf youtube ist jedes
unserer workshops traf ja ihr könnt das
alles nachlesen nachschauen nachhören
und nach trainieren morgen kommt die
gefreite vassiliki alexandr zu uns eine
synchronschwimmerin klar ja wir werden
mit sportartspezifischen jetzt das große
indoor pool aufbauen das geht sie in der
winterzeit das schafft man nicht aber
die beweglichkeit ist super super
zubringer für die synchron schwimmer und
schwimmerinnen unter wärme entsprechend
von diesem know how nutzen von der
basilika und entsprechend dorf im
bereich mobilität und regeneration
wieder mitarbeiten gegen abschluss der
trainingswoche zwei sommer desto mehr am
programm und wir freuen uns natürlich
wenn ihr morgen genauso mit dabei ist
zum regenerationstraining okay
die pause ist so fortgeschritten ich
glaube 30 sekunden das richtig gesehen
habe
ich sehe daher wird mobilisiert die
letzten kräfte für die liegestütze die
richtig richtig fordern sei wie nik page
in froher erwartung so zu sagen dass es
endlich weiter geht die fahrt vor
energie
30 sekunden dann los die diese bereiche
zinssätzen zwischen drinnen der
kreislauf haben darunter kann man stets
auf 20 an wieder zu bewegen weil in 20
sekunden statt mit dem zweiten durchgang
ist bereit oder bereit das wurde die
herren noch zehn sekunden dann geht's
wieder los denn schon mal die position
einnehmen
in 321 und los geht's 20 sekunden
liegestütz wandern und wie gesagt wenn
der liegestütz sie greifen immer ganz
ausgeht dann waren das nur auf und ab
halbzeit durchbeißen atmen atmen ganz
wichtig zwei sekunden eine erste übung
wieder vorbei du machst das extraschicht
lieneke mit den unbedingt noch fertig
machen sehr gehört das kreuz motivation
ist da zwei sekunden eine startchance
und kniebeugen im breiten stand achtet
wie gesagt bei den kniebeugen auf einen
stabilen geraden rücken muskulär
abgesichert die visuelle die beinachse
passen und in der dynamik ist es
natürlich genauso wichtig dass sich
diese stabilität aufrecht erhalten und
in 321 10 sekunden stationen wechsel
zweite übung abgeschlossen
wechsel auf die bauchmuskulatur drei
sekunden
arnstadt
und die spannung fast halbzeit ist
geschafft zehn sekunden seien schon
vorbei mit der dynamik vorkommen genau
und dann bremsen und ausgleichen
20 sekunden vor bei zehn sekunden
station wechseln gewicht ablegen
wir gehen in den streik sprung mit oder
ohne liegestütz und in die blöcke
variante mit liegestütze jetzt zeit
läuft körperspannung halten braucht es
angespannt rücken ist angespannt
halbzeit zehn sekunden
[Applaus]
21 10 sekunden station wechseln
wir beginnen wieder mit dem wege steht
die letzte übung volle konzentration auf
liegestütze 2 1 los geht's
und hat es schon wieder geschafft wo
sekunden habe mir jetzt noch kommt aus
sehr gut star james keineswegs profis
die letzten drei übungen wir starten in
drei zwei eins los geht's schöne dynamik
in der bewegung zehn sekunden mit der
dynamik hoch gajic um herbert kämpfen
kämpfen kämpfen beißen januar super 21
oder sehr gut deswegen volle belastung
das ist hartes workout bauchmuskeln
jetzt unter an der feier quasi unter
voller belastung in 21 und los geht's
atmen nicht vergessen schnaps aus sivas
geht ja laste sauerstoff in ein noch
fünf sekunden fünf sekunden 21 oder
summer nach station wechsel immer noch
trabis einmal noch strikt sprung mit
liegestütz wir starten in drei sekunden
letzte übung motiviert los geht's 15
noch zehn gadget ja wort super machte
das 5 sekunden
die letzte wiederholung geht's raus
kommst 21 und vorbei durchschnaufen los
wie gesagt den kreislauf in schwung geht
ein bisschen um atom nicht sofort
einsetzen drinks anschlug bewegt sagt
kreis die arme mobilisiert das becken
bewegung ganz wichtig langsam den
kreislauf unterkommen müssen nicht
abrupt ihn setzen hinlegen meister
kreislauf verlangt wenn es schwierig
wird klar keine frage amazonas ausgehen
auslauf kann
sie ist daher wert bewegt sich die nicht
bewegt die strahlen vor glück ja
training workout ist erledigt jawohl es
war super anstrengend und das macht es
aus meiner training richtig anstrengend
ist und richtig gas geben haben in dem
in der arbeit dann ist man doch
natürlich voller endorphine voller
positiver energie und besiegten habe die
zwar als auch bewegen ausnahme
vielleicht ein bisserl baumeln lassen
habe so ausschüttungen die atmung
kontrollieren 345 x wirklich tief ein
und ausatmen jeder in seinem rhythmus
richtig schlucken trinken den mund
befeuchten genau so isses konzentrieren
körper runter fahren
meine bitte hin setzen auf die matte
mobil ist hier immer noch mal im bereich
vom rücken der mann wirklich gefordert
haben das heißt eine leicht öffnen die
knie hin und her fallen lassen und sich
gesagt durchschnaufen runterkommen
system runterfahren aus lockern
dann noch mal noch einen lockeren krebs
bitte dann auf die zehenspitzen der
mengen und her dass ein ganzer
entspannenden übungen genau ohne stress
ohne druck ohne power jetzt aus lockern
mobilisieren
jawohl nicke ich sage danke fürs
wirklich eine beißende bei der super
gemacht tolle leistung für euch zu hause
natürlich auch ein hartes intensives
workout ihr habt es geschafft wir haben
super super cool und intensiv trainiert
das wars für heute sind viele gesagt wir
freuen uns auf morgen auf das ausland
das regenerieren auf die beweglichkeit
an der wir morgen arbeiten schönen
nackten auf und wir sehen uns morgen